sniper elite five it's a big old sandbox
now and you can approach levels in a lot
of different ways you can make those
sweet long range shots or you can just
humiliate the crap out of nazis some
things of the game surprised us on our
first run so we're here to teach you 10
things that we wish we knew before
starting sniper elite 5.
normally i'd start a guide like this
with the fundamentals but i'd just
rather start with my favorite mechanic
of the entire game that's right we're
going to talk about the humble bottle
bottles can knock soldiers out with a
well placed shot to the head and because
you throw it in an arc it's one of the
few weapons in the game that can do this
over the top of cover while an enemy is
fully hunkered down bottles can be used
to quickly take down two guards standing
side by side which otherwise you'd need
your co-op buddy to do
or if you're an absolute stone cold
killer you can lay a mine lure a nazi
over then knock them out so they fall on
top of that mine which is more humane i
think
[Music]
this sniper elite game will give you an
x-ray kill cam on a wide array of kills
now which includes knives and pistols so
believe me when i say that you won't
miss out if you focus your initial
upgrades on the 1911 pistol instead of
your first sniper rifle many of the maps
in this game are massive and chances of
pulling off that full stealth run
initially are pretty low unless you have
a lot of patience and you're willing to
reload a lot of saves for many of you
though there's gonna be panic moments
where you run across a guard and in
order to not alert the entire level
you're gonna have to rely on a fast
firing suppressed backup weapon like the
1911. you can upgrade it early and you
should within the first three levels i
already had one kitted out with a stock
scope and some armor-piercing ammo it
was basically a mini sniper rifle
[Music]
while we're talking about guns in this
game there are a few things to make use
of here you can now use iron sights on
all weapons but more importantly the
game remembers which gun you have in
third person and which guns in first
person so with a little prep work at the
start of each round you can get your
precision guns and iron sights and your
smgs and panic weapons in third person
that way you can adapt to situations
quickly such as how you definitely want
to be in third person inside of
buildings to see what's around you don't
forget that in third person you can
shoulder swap and you should always
round corners from the correct side
there's also now an active reload
mechanic that you have to pay attention
to especially in the middle of a loud
firefight make sure to nail the reload
quickly but also remember it's still
usually faster to go to another weapon
these levels are massive i may said this
a bunch of times already and there's a
lot of ways through them and items to
find like weapon benches and caches keys
crowbars and explosives these items let
you customize weapons get into locked
chests and open up new routes across the
map give yourself permission it's okay
to fudge your first run and get around
quickly to learn where these things are
before pulling off that sweet stealth
run another advantage is that although
you will unlock some items through play
you need to find weapon benches to open
up certain gun attachments like the
suppressor for your starting sniper
rifle
invasions can be confusing at first
especially if you're the one being
invaded this is where another player
enters your game as one of the enemy
soldiers and tries to take you out
unlike dark souls you're not going to
know who this enemy player is they don't
have like a tint or anything like that
if you're invaded stop playing against
the environment and focus all of your
energy on hunting that other player down
you're at a huge disadvantage if you try
to manage both the level objectives and
the playerverse player aspects it's
pretty easy for the invading player to
just follow the sounds of your gunshots
and track you down so the first thing
you need to do is swap all of your
weapons to whatever the quietest thing
that you have the levels will have
phones scattered around that you can
find or are marked on the minimap go
find one and call it to see where the
other player is likely to be knowing
they're actually doing the exact same
thing at the exact same time there's
some sneaky things you can do like booby
trap phones you think they're likely to
use kill enemies and trap their bodies
or set up on a sight line but you're not
allowed to camp the game will give you a
couple warnings and then just physically
kill you if you try it
you have plenty of options when it comes
to distracting enemies for example many
explosives will let you set short or
long-term timers set a long timer and
then sneak around the other side so when
it goes off it'll pull the guards away
and you can slip on by you'll find these
short and long timers also on some types
of mines and enemy lures to get extra
lethal put a lower down on top of a
landmine then there's bottles which yes
we are still talking about they can be
used to turn an enemy away from you even
when they're actively spotting you feel
free to combo distractions and
explosives and a lot of different ways
to do things like lure some guards over
to some tnt you tossed on the ground
honestly it's really fun to just mess
with the bad guys in this game
[Music]
you can't throw mines but you can mine a
body and throw that this is useful if
enemies are just below you and you're
out of grenades there isn't much more to
say about this i just wanted to tell you
the most powerful weapon in the game is
your hard knuckles for better or worse
enemies in sniper elite aren't too
bright and if you stand in a doorway and
whistle you can quickly build up a huge
pile of bodies because they just keep
falling for that one over and over again
keep this strategy in mind if you're
running low on ammo in general melee
takedowns are faster than guns and have
a surprisingly decent range
[Music]
we may have mentioned earlier several
times that some of these levels are
massive like it took one of us over two
hours to get through the first mission
silently there's a good chance you'll
get spotted and enemies in sniper elite
5 tend to escalate to higher levels of
alarm pretty quick that means a lot of
you will choose a faster run and gun
style to give you a better chance there
are a few things you can focus on first
the main three things are shooting out
alarms as you come across them taking
down officers first to weaken their
squads and setting up a ton of random
minds as well as booby traps on dead
enemy soldiers laying lots of mines in
traps creates a lot of chaos and that
confuses the ai as to where you are
there's a good chance you'll be in the
middle of getting swarmed at some point
and some explosive will go off halfway
across the map drawing them away from
you and saving your life the other
critical thing is to invest early unlock
tree points in the combat skill tree go
for back to the fight that allows you to
self revive as long as you have a med
pack then head on over to the far right
tree which is called body and pick up
health boost 1 and 2 so you can take
more damage as you progress in the game
you can use workbenches to build pretty
lethal running gun loadouts with close
range sniper rifles a baller 1911 pistol
and better smgs you can even use
non-lethal bullets which are very
effective at quickly knocking out
soldiers
for you milsim enthusiasts out there the
game still has an authentic mode which
vastly reduces hud information and
cranks up environmental factors that
affect your bullet in flight although
this is the most difficult standard mode
you can go into custom settings and make
it even harder if you want to at the
default hardest difficulty though here's
how to make those long range shots being
a video game this isn't totally
realistic and that's kind of helpful you
still get two main pieces of information
the ability to scan targets with your
binoculars to get the range which you
can then dial into your scope and also
inside your scope you get windage and
drop indicators which tell you how far a
bullet will drift up down left or right
after you fire it these two hatch marks
here give you that information it's a
lot less precise than on easier modes
this works for your scope equipped
pistols as well
you can then dial that range into your
scope that's helpful because if you have
to dial in say 400 meters for a target
under 400 meters the hatch marks will
indicate that you actually need to aim a
little bit low on the hardest difficulty
more than other modes you'll need to go
prone and listen to your heart
when your heart rate is slow your scopes
cross hairs will drift less which helps
avoid throwing a shot off target that
matters because without scope drift from
breathing and heart rate etc your rifle
will settle dead on your binoculars last
position and just swapping between the
two will place your crosshairs right on
target definitely aim center of mass at
long range because heads are too small
when it comes to hiding your position
wait for that loud noise like passing
airplanes before you take your shot
guards will alert more quickly and
aggressively if they hear you we
generally found anything at 100 to 200
meters to be pretty consistent with the
rest of the game at 300 meters shots got
pretty tricky mostly because of how tiny
targets in the distance appeared at 400
meters shots became very difficult and
sometimes it was easier to get an
environmental kill using a larger target
in the area for example this gargoyle
was larger and easier to hit than the
enemy sniper patrolling below it it is
fun when it all works out
so that should get you started with
sniper elite 5. what's something that
surprised you in the game and what's
something fun you learned that other
players could use these were just our
initial experiences let us know in the
comments below we cover a ton of first
person and third person shooters so join
us over on gamespot and gamespot's
youtube page thanks for watching
[Music]
you